we're back and the day after Earth Day
2018 and one of the most important
issues that we're dealing with as humans
is what we're doing to the climate and
much of what the current President of
the United States is doing can be rolled
back and in some areas the damage done
can be sort of undone to some degree but
you can't undo years of damaging our
planet the only planet that we at least
for now have to live on and the best
analogy I can think of it sort of like a
huge ocean liner or a large commercial
plane that's sailing or flying in the
wrong direction the amount of time and
fuel and effort to reroute it after
every minute that it's going in the
wrong direction grows and in some cases
grows exponentially if a commercial
airliner is off target for 15 minutes
that could potentially add 30 minutes in
total to the flight time that you would
have had from point A to point B if the
plane had been going in the right
direction from the get-go and that
effect can grow even more over time and
that's sort of an analogy for climate
change right the amount of damage that
Donald Trump and his administration will
do relative to what another president
might have done in a four-year term
could take us way more than four years
to undo and on that note Earth Day was
yesterday April 22nd 2018 and Donald
Trump and his White House put out an
Earth Day statement really in name only
and orwellian is really the only way
that I can describe it and what I'm
referencing is George Orwell's book 1984
that book included the terms doublethink
and Newspeak and those have been sort of
colloquially blended together into the
term doublespeak the idea of ambiguous
speech by definition of by by design in
order to be deceptive or speech that
means the opposite of what it sounds
like and that's sort of what I mean when
I say that Donald Trump's Earth Day
statement was Orwellian in nature
because Earth Day is supposed to be
about
supporting environmental protection
taking care of our planet that's what
it's been about since 1970 when it was
first celebrated this is a global event
nearly 200 countries participating and
Donald Trump's Earth Day statement
celebrated the destruction that is being
done to the environment by his
administration let's take a look at a
piece of that statement that was put out
where the Trump administration said in
the second paragraph quote we also know
that a strong market driven economy is
essential to protecting these resources
meaning natural earth resources for this
reason my administration is dedicated to
removing unnecessary and harmful
regulations that restrain economic
growth and make it more difficult for
local communities to prosper and to
choose the best solutions for their
environment that's the exact opposite of
the reality right market-driven is
what's causing the problem not enough
regulation on industry since
industrialization right for the last
hundred and fifty two hundred years
that's been the catalyst for the
situation we now find ourselves in
Trump's administration has destroyed
countless Obama era environmental
protection regulations doing more damage
to the environment by their removal and
Trump's EPA director Scott Pruett who by
the way we've learned is the subject of
ten federal investigations right now
I'll tell you about that a little bit
later
Trump's EPA director Scott Pruett has
announced that he's going to be gutting
fuel standards that were meant to cut
carbon emissions those will be gone soon
Trump's administration has a plan to do
more offshore drilling which does more
damage to the environment so Trump's
message on Earth Day is we love the
earth protect the earth I guess which
he's going to do by removing regulations
and allowing industry to further destroy
the planet the Earth Day statement from
Trump is the opposite of what Earth Day
is supposed to be about or in other
words
Earth Day
made Trump make a statement that he's
going to do exactly what earth day is
supposed to stop it's like a speech on I
mean I don't know Martin Luther King Day
about how the president is going to work
hard to get us back to like the era of
Jim Crow or something I don't know if
that's a good analogy or a speech on
Holocaust Remembrance Day about how the
president is going to finally get to the
bottom of those crafty Jews controlling
the banking industry maybe these are bad
analogies the guy seems to be saying
that to have a clean environment a safe
environment a healthy planet
corporations must thrive when
corporations are the ones that have by
and large done the economic destruction
when we've left them unchecked but I
guess we have clean coal now or
something if you ask Donald Trump
totally clean beautiful coal and the the
real point I want to make here the
statement is totally Orwellian the
broader absurdity here is that we have
this Earth Day thing once a year which I
support I agree with it's a beautiful
thing 200 countries nearly getting
involved but then we elect politicians
nationwide who deny climate change
altogether or at least deny that climate
change is connected to human activities
they represent this year-round and we
have Earth Day once a year it's
absolutely disgusting
unconscionable and immoral what we are
doing and at the top of the list of
problems related to Earth Day is the guy
running the EPA Scott Pruett which is
what I want to talk to you about next
okay I didn't think we'd be going back
to the supposed P tape a possible video
recording of Donald Trump with
prostitutes in Russia possibly engaging
in or maybe just watching them engage in
various sexualized urine related rituals
I'm really using very very the cleanest
possible language to talk about this but
Trump's been caught in his first live
related to the supposed P tape and I
want to be super clear here so I'm going
to say this twice I'm gonna say this now
and I'm gonna say it after I explain the
lie the reason this is a big deal is not
because it proves that the P tape is
real the P tape may not be real this is
a big deal because
is evidence that Trump is lying about
the facts related to the P tape and
Trump often has a pattern of lying about
small elements of a story first and then
the disproving of those small elements
leads to an understanding that it's all
a big lie okay so that that's the
disclaimer what happened
we've now learned through various
interviews given by the fired FBI
director James Comey that Trump
specifically wanted to convince Comey
when they met that the P tape rumor
wasn't true okay and according to Comey
Trump said a few things in sort of his
defense one is that he's a germaphobe or
something along those lines the other is
that it's not possible that Trump was
involved in the urine stuff with Russian
prostitutes or prostitutes in Russia
because he never spent the night in
Moscow back in 2013 around the time of
the Miss Universe pageant that was held
there this is the trip during which it
supposedly happened if it did Trump
insisted he left on a plane the same day
the same night and that apparently
implied in that is that if you're gonna
do urine fetish prostitute stuff in a
hotel room you'd have to do it in the
middle of the night or very very very
late at night now any normal person
could say you know it could also happen
during the day but let's stick with
Donald Trump's story which is it's not
possible because he didn't stay over
let's look at a piece of James commis
writing about the situation where Comey
said Comey said he said he had spoken to
people who had been on the Miss Universe
trip with him and they had reminded him
that he didn't stay overnight in Russia
for that he said he arrived in the
morning did events then showered and
dressed for the pageant at the hotel he
didn't say the hotel name and left for
the pageant afterwards he returned only
to get his things because they departed
for New York by plane that same night so
Trump's alibi so to speak is he didn't
spend the night he left the same day up
until now there was the suspicion that
that's not true that Trump actually
stayed in Moscow for two nights which
immediately contradicts his supposed
alibi but now Bloomberg is able to
disprove that claim specifically because
they have the flight records and what we
have learned is that Donald Trump flew
to Moscow on November 7th of 2013 not
his plane but on a private jet owned by
Phil Ruffin who's one of trumps business
partners that plane landed in Moscow on
November 8th accounting for the time
changed the time zone difference later
on November 8th Trump went to eat at
Nobu Moscow the sushi restaurant Nobu
Moscow the next day November 9th there
are Facebook posts that show Trump was
at the Ritz Hotel during the day that's
already won overnight and Trump tweeted
that he had a tour of Moscow on that day
and then later Trump went to the Miss
Universe pageant itself then went to an
after party and that after-party started
at 1:00 a.m. November 10th
so remember Trump arrived November 8th
and he's there at least until 1:00 a.m.
November 10th which is almost two full
days later later that night the plane
that Trump flew to Moscow in left at
4:00 a.m. meaning that even if Trump was
on that plane and let's assume that he
was he spent the better part of two full
nights in Moscow so that directly
disproves Trump's story and the timeline
so let's go back to what I started with
because it's the most important thing
here I'm not saying that the fact that
Trump lied about not having spent any
nights in Moscow proves that the P tape
is real or that the prostitute story is
real whether or not there is a video
recording it's a big deal because Trump
is now lying about his supposed alibi
when it comes to the P tape and when I
step back from it I don't know what the
truth is
but it's weird that there's been so much
focus by Trump on the existence or
nonexistence of this p tape and it's
also weird that too many specifics from
Trump about something that supposedly
didn't happen seem to be wrong and it's
also kind of weird I'm thinking like if
someone came to me with this I would
just say there's no tape because it's
not something I did period I wouldn't
say well you know I'm very germaphobic
you know I wouldn't really get involved
would get involved in urine stuff with
Russian prostitutes or you know it the
timing of it like it's basically a
scheduling conflict right like when you
say it couldn't have it didn't happen
because I didn't overnight in Moscow
you're not saying it's something you
wouldn't do you're just saying like the
timing
didn't allow for it which is a really
weird way to defend yourself yeah I feel
like there are two possibilities here
one is that it's like the one aspect of
the Christopher Steele dossier that's
not true and Trump thought that he could
easily debunk it so that's why he wanted
to zero in on that yeah the other
possibility is that pretty much
everything in the Steele dossier is true
but because Trump found this to be like
the most damaging to his reputation most
hellacious the most embarrassing he
wanted to make sure that that was off
the record there's a third possibility
which is maybe he was given wrong
information about overnighting and like
it still didn't happen but the alibi
can't be that he didn't overnight there
or something like that but the bottom
line is these are not exactly normal
reactions in light of these accusations
and you know what in the end Hillary
Clinton reportedly urinated multiple
times during the 2016 presidential
campaign Comey is not talking about it
Fox News isn't - nobody's talking about
the fact that Hillary Clinton was
urinating all throughout that campaign
and we're only hearing about Trump and
urine in the middle of debates no less
she would leave and not be back for the
commercial break though right we in fact
Donald Trump calling attention to it at
one point so lie confirmed about the P
tape stuff it's not actually about the P
tape it's about the fact that Trump has
been caught lying again about something
that a normal person would just say I
didn't do that and there's no evidence
that I did it because it didn't happen
let's talk about a visit to the United
States by French president Emmanuel
macron who went to Washington DC
yesterday first state dinner took place
last night the entire thing was a gong
show from the get-go and I'm gonna get
to Donald Trump's statement about his -
plus our meeting with McCrone
momentarily but just to give you first a
little bit of the flavor for the endless
string of bizarre faux pause each
outdoing the previous in terms of
Trump's meeting with world leaders
during a photo-op in the White House
Donald Trump at one point claimed to be
wiping dandruff off of the shoulder of
the French president and the funniest
thing if you're watching you'll be able
to hear what Trump says whether you're
listening or watching if you're watching
you'll also be able to observe the look
on Emmanuel macron face when Donald
Trump is due
this and it is it's an amazing reaction
by virtue of non reaction McCrone sort
of stone-faced with a smile right like a
an immovable smile on his face as Donald
Trump claims to be wiping dandruff off
of the French president's suit take a
look at this take a listen to this mr.
president they're all saying what a
great relationship we have and they're
actually correct it's not fake news
finally it's not fake news so it's a
great honor great honor that you hear
but we do have a very special
relationship in fact I'll get that
little piece of dandruff little piece we
have to make them perfect he is perfect
so it is really it is really great to be
with you and your special friend thank
you thank you thank you thank you again
thank you very much mr. president
yeah interestingly that was the least
cringe-worthy moment of the entire visit
so it only got worse from there and they
did a sort of statement after their
meeting they were sitting across from
each other at a table Mike Pence was
next to draught Trump and Jim mattis and
a John Bolton was on Trump's side of the
table and everything about it was just
transmitting a very very strange
atmosphere let's go through a few clips
from the meeting we're going to have a
short little meeting and it turned out
to be a long meeting and it could have
gone on for another two hours we
discussed a lot of things a lot of
problems in the world a lot of problems
that we think can be solved we've come a
long way just the two of us I think is
understanding when we talked about Iran
we talked about Syria we talked about a
lot of subjects that really are big big
hard situations and we think we have
solutions to a number of them so we're
going to continue that now and then
Emanuel and myself will meet again I
think after this meeting right aside
from Trump referring to them going over
a number of big hard situations that
that actually again I that's not the
weirdest part of this what's weird I
think is sort of a couple things number
one there's this attitude from Trump
generally that like he's bad
McCrone right on some level he's just
he's a better he's a better man he's a
better person he's more important than
McCrone but also there's this feeling
like it's all sort of a bother to him
like he he's sort of yeah I'm doing this
and we had a meeting we could have met
longer we talked about trade I set the
agenda but it's all kind of like from a
point of condescension isn't that it's
going through the motions he's talking
about law without saying anything and I
kind of wish I could do that too you're
just like well in the air well and what
he ended up doing is just going very
quickly into bragging about random
random things right so there's no real
indication that he actually saw the
content of the meeting with the French
president is that important because he
immediately jumped in to bragging about
unemployment rates in different states
take a look very good numbers are coming
out on our businesses you see the
numbers that are getting released on our
companies and our businesses they're
very strong the economy is is been
really incredible unemployment now is at
the lowest point ever in history in many
many states the states were enumerated
last night late last night the numbers
came out and we've hit the lowest
unemployment numbers in many decades in
some cases and in some cases the lowest
number is period it was just reiterated
that unemployment for African American
families it's been the best in history
for Hispanic families the best in
history for women the best in eighteen
years and that's very close to going
much higher than that so it's really
something very special so we're very
happy about that it's like what is he
talking about if you're a manual McCrone
and you're sitting there across from him
what what do you make of the fact that
Trump is just making absolutely no sense
and a lot of the stuff he said wasn't
even true he said we've just gotten the
net we've gotten the numbers from our
companies and everything's great the Dow
crashed 500 points yesterday
unanticipated bad earnings numbers like
where is Trump getting this stuff and it
just went on like this for a while I
don't know what is going through the
French president's head as this is going
on and then Trump talks about his
conversation with McCrone again this
time saying they talked about trade
which I'm sure they did but it's made
abundantly clear that Trump doesn't know
anything about Trey
look at this the president and I working
on trade the trade with France is
complicated because we have the European
Union I would rather deal just with
France the Union is very tough for us
that they have trade barriers that are
unacceptable our farmers can't send
their product into the European Union
easily as they should and we accept
their product so we have to make a
change and they understand that if we're
negotiating Wilbur and Steve and
everybody we're negotiating with the
European Union yeah but he's doing a
great job and then trade apparently got
Trump into talking about China where it
really got strange take a look at this
last clip is we have no choice but to be
very serious
you know we've put on very substantial
tariffs and that will continue unless we
make a trade deal I think we're we've
got a very good chance of making a deal
as you know they've just stated
President Xi a terrific guy and a friend
of mine but he's representing China and
I'm representing the United States
president she made a speech four days
ago where he said that China is going to
be opened up it's not opened up right
now they trade with us we can't trade
with them they did 504 billion dollars
last year and we did a hundred and
twenty billion dollars that's a
tremendous imbalance that we can't have
that yeah the key moment there was when
Trump clarified that he represents the
United States and trade deals it's
actually good to clarify that often I
don't know whose side Trump is on from
what he says so it's good that he said
by the way I do represent the United
States here sort of a verbal Rorschach
test of sorts right he later talked
about North Korea I won't subject you to
that stuff and then finally Emmanuel
macron gets a chance to speak and I
realized in his non-native English
McCrone is more articulate and better
able to communicate in a sort of
reasonable human way than Donald Trump
is and with that thank you all very much
mr. president would you like to say
something
Thank You mr. president
well he's working on that system not
meeting with benefit wine together again
before the press conference just to say
it had a very good discussion and indeed
in Syria Iran the oval region and some
other very important topics regarding
our security and I think we we have to
work together because we've always
worked together on these issues and it's
very important to preserve the stability
of this region and I think what we want
to what we want to do is in the rest of
our people is precisely to preserve
stability sovereign states without an e
ikemen paratus so Emmanuel macron
putting a final point on that and I
decided to wade into online comments
about this entire thing and the trumpets
are just loving it right despite the
fact that Trump looks like he just woke
up at that table and all of a sudden
said wow there's cameras here and I
should say something Oh Trump must be
playing 4d chess it's just unbelievable
every move he makes are so carefully
crafted and just brilliant in every way
so we're not probably gonna agree with
those folks they also like to when Trump
was being adversarial with macrons know
I guess they can have it either way
shorting before there was like the
handshake games yeah now there's the
kissing yeah grooming I like it all
really we're kissing and grooming each
other a lot in hand holding hands and
stuff it was just every every detail
down to the smallest minutiae bizarre
and unexplainable in so many ways and
we'll see what the eventual diplomatic
repercussions are of this very strange
and bizarre visit send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman shows on
twitter at david pakman show quick break
back after this things are really not
looking up for fox news propagandists
sean hannity who of course has both
radio and television programs and this
actually goes back to our vacation last
week when trump's lawyer michael cohen
revealed in court or his lawyers did
that sean hannity is a client of Michael
Cohen's which immediately called into
question why Hannity didn't disclose
that when reporting critically about the
way that Cohen was being investigated by
robert muller hannity also immediately
denied that cohen was his lawyer which
if you believe the denial directly
implies that perjury took place that
direct lies were told in
that courtroom when the claim was made
that Cohen represented at some point or
currently Sean Hannity but the broader
picture is now becoming more and more
clear as we learn number one that Donald
Trump regularly talks to Sean Hannity
has had him at the White House for
dinner and it's not just a friendly
relationship because we're also learning
that Sean Hannity has a sort of many
real-estate empire that's connected to
Trump administration staffers including
cabinet secretary ben Carson and part of
Hannity's denial of Michael Cohen being
his attorney included Hannity saying
quote I've said many times on my radio
show I hate the stock market I prefer
real estate Michael Cohen knows real
estate so basically what Hannity is
saying here is Cohen wasn't my lawyer I
was talking to him informally about real
estate and the Guardian started looking
into Hannity's real estate holdings and
it turns out that he has a ton of real
estate that was not previously reported
and much of that real estate ownership
is through shell companies that spend
more than or have spent more than ninety
million dollars on nearly nine hundred
homes in seven states over the last ten
years and Hannity is the sort of hidden
owner of these properties many of those
properties purchased at a discount in
2013 after a huge string of foreclosures
stemming from the mortgage crisis that
was going on at the time and the double
standard here of Hannity slamming Obama
for what was taking place despite the
fact that it wasn't actually Obama's
fault
but personally taking advantage of it
and profiting from it is just disgusting
but that's not all there's another
concerning element here Hannity was
supported by the United States
Department of Housing and Urban
Development which he did not disclose
when he was praising ben Carson
endlessly Trump's Secretary of Housing
and Urban Development is ben Carson he's
been on Sean Hannity's program before
and some of the properties that Hannity
bought including some in the state of
Georgia were bought with mortgages
that the Department of Housing and Urban
Development helped Sean Hannity obtain
through something called the National
Housing Act and the loans were upped by
five million dollars with support from
none other than Ben Carson's HUD
Department Hannity has interviewed Ben
Carson and never disclosed his financial
interest when talking to Carson about
HUD and housing policy he just praised
privatization that Donald Trump and
Carson wanted to do it is all incredibly
sketchy Hannity reports on Michael Cohen
without mentioning that Cohen is his
attorney or was or is his real estate
adviser Hannity interviews ben Carson
and praises the policy without
mentioning that he's working with HUD to
obtain gigantic loans to buy properties
that he then I guess presumably rent out
Hannity also works with the wealth
management firm whose principal is Bill
Aiko who Hannity has interviewed on his
program without disclosing that
relationship and that same bill Leigh
co-wrote op-eds slamming the robert
muller investigation and no disclosure
whatsoever total propagandist and total
lack of disclosure and once again the
guys screaming about corruption by obama
corruption by robert muller he's
actually the guy covering up the massive
conflicts of interest here yeah and i
remember after Trump became president
people started calling Fox News
state-run media yeah because they were
just Peres whatever the administration's
position is and then later on we were
like actually maybe it's media run state
because Trump will get up at 5:00 in the
morning and watch Fox and Friends and
then tweet whatever the anchors say and
run his policy based on what the anchors
on Fox have to say sure now it's like I
don't know which one it is state-run
media media runs state it's so
intertwined if this book is basically
just a melting pot of the two together
and I don't think anybody in our
audience is going to be surprised that
Hannity's radio and TV programs not only
are they trading in total propaganda
it's actually calculated profiteering
for Sean Hannity personally from the
propaganda that he puts out not at all
surprising to me and at least he's a
super nice guy right and I still stand
by that when I met Sean Hannity he was
way nicer to me
then most of the progressive media
people tom hartman was the best nicest
guy
same thing with junk huger but a lot of
the progressive media people were really
not nice when I met them and Hannity was
a super nice guy did Hannity know your
politics though uh yeah you were
conservative didn't matter
didn't matter just was not was not even
an issue I wonder if he's sort of
playing a character kind of like he's
fun savvy
Alex Jones of playing if he's playing a
character it's one that's very
personally profitable for him so it's an
incredibly valuable business character
for him that's for damn sure I've got an
update for you on a notable 2018 midterm
race it is MIT Romney MIT Romney as the
former Massachusetts governor the former
failed presidential candidate former a
co eater of was it turtle soup or frogs
legs or some both both that he was
having with trumpet some restaurant he's
running for US senator from Utah Trump
has endorsed him he needs to officially
become the Republican nominee for that
seat in order to make it to the general
election in November of this year and he
is at least that his first opportunity
failed to secure that nomination there's
actually now going to be a June primary
for the race because Mitt Romney failed
to get even a plurality of the vote
never mind the 60% that is required to
avoid a primary in Utah State
Representative Mike Kennedy got just
over 50% Mitt Romney got just over 49%
and because neither of them got 60%
there are now there is now a I guess a
real primary has been triggered for lack
of a better term in June stunning for a
couple of reasons number one is that
Trump endorsement aside mitt romney is
way way way more well known than state
Rep Mike Kennedy so that raises
questions about whether there's sort of
resentment in Utah that Romney I mean
yeah he has a house in Utah and he's had
one there for a long time but doesn't
really live there sort of like a showing
up to run kind of situation may be
triggering some resentment that's one
possibility the other angle is that
Romney does have the endorsements not
only of the president Donald Trump but
also of retiring senator
Hach whose seat he's running for and he
still wasn't able to secure the
nomination and when Romney first
announced that he was running he wasn't
even expected to have a serious primary
challenger and now he didn't even get a
plurality of the vote and the question
I'm most interested in is how
prominently is Donald Trump gonna
campaign for Romney between now and the
June primary because we know that Trump
only likes winners period Romney failing
to even get a plurality of the vote and
not helpful to Romley intro to Romney is
that if he wants Trump's help he over
the weekend refused to say whether he's
either even supporting Donald Trump for
re-election in 2020 you might remember
that Donald Trump either on the day that
he was inaugurated or the day after
filed for re-election and part of it
seems to be that that allows him to
continue raising money in a particular
way but he's running for re-election is
the long and short of it Romney was
asked over the weekend so are you
supporting Donald Trump's candidacy for
2020 and Romney said he's going to be
making that decision further down the
road so what can we take from this well
number one should we deduce that a
Democrat has a chance in Utah no that is
not what this is about I do not see any
path for a Democratic candidate to win a
Senate race in very conservative and
very very Mormon Utah but the signal
here is that number one a trump
endorsement is not a guarantee of a path
not even to victory overall but even to
a path the Republican nomination we saw
that in Alabama and we potentially are
going to see that in Utah that's
interesting and number two seemingly
anything could happen in the midterms
now yeah not a Democrat becoming the
next senator from Utah but seemingly
almost anything could happen and that's
why people need to vote right no matter
what state you're in no matter which
race you're talking about this is going
to be a wacky midterm it is arguably
going to come down to voter turnout and
I guess you could say when voter turnout
is around 50% even less in midterms kind
of all comes down to voter turnout and
no matter where you are don't stay home
as the message I think there are
definitely places where Democrats and
win but Utah I don't think is one of
those places now in 2012 when Romney ran
against Obama Romney picked like 72
percent of the vote he won that state by
a larger margin than any other state
it's just not the right place and maybe
he's losing some support now because
there's that Scott Brown effect where
people are saying you're not really from
Utah but I think he will ultimately win
you think that Romney is gonna do sure
interesting that I I'm wondering I mean
I guess it's going to have to just be a
turnout play right because he didn't
even get it's not like there was some
third candidate who took a ton of the
vote there was basically 1% or so in
there
split up among people that were not
Kennedy nor Romney so do you think that
voter turnouts just gonna be higher in
the June primary and that it's gonna
disproportionately go to Romney I think
I think the name recognition will help
Romney certainly there are setbacks I
don't think being tied to Trump is a
good thing for him yeah so he'll want to
leave the Trump endorsement at just that
tweet and nothing more and interesting
that he's leaving a tepid response and
saying that he's not necessarily going
to support Trump for 2020 yeah I think
people will just walk on eggshells
through this entire race but he'll skate
through and we'll no matter what you say
about Utah Mormons and either one of us
could say many many things very very
concerning things what you can say and
we saw this evidenced by the Utah
numbers in the 2016 presidential
election Utah Mormons don't love the
Trump thing and Evan McMullen getting
significant support in Utah in 2016 and
so having clearly in Utah more than in
many other states just having a trump
endorsement is not a path to victory
even in the Republican primary there's
this sort of conventional wisdom or
common sense or actually both of those
terms often don't make sense but there
is this sort of conventional wisdom that
trump voters made the choice to vote for
Donald Trump because of so-called
economic anxiety right and that in
particular Trump was sort of speaking to
the economic anxieties of middle class
and often rural white voters to a better
degree to a greater degree than Hillary
Clinton did and so voila they voted for
Donald Trump instead of Hill
a Clinton and the New York Times is a
really good report out on a new study by
the Proceedings of the National Academy
of Sciences that points in a very very
different direction and one that I
actually think makes more more sense
when you really examine it critically to
explain why many trumpets ended up
voting for Donald Trump and so it is
true that according to this study the
white male voting contingent
particularly the white Christian male
voting contingent was moved to vote for
Trump but not by economic anxiety but
instead by fear of losing their status
and the study found that mostly people
voted along party lines as is typically
the case in presidential elections
Republicans mostly voted for Donald
Trump Democrats mostly voted for Hillary
Clinton but among independents and among
people who cross voted meaning Democrats
voting for Trump or Republicans voting
for Hillary Clinton
those who ended up voting for Donald
Trump were disproportionately likely to
see their status in society as
threatened in some way more likely to
see whites and or Christians and/or men
as facing new discrimination and this is
not just like a cherry pick data point
while every other study says no economic
anxiety was the reason there's another
study the Public Religion Research
Institute did a similar survey and it
also found that this contingent of white
Christian men were moved to vote for
Trump disproportionately because of
their fear of being displaced in the
culture which is a very similar result
and when you think about it it makes a
lot of sense did voters really care
about bad trade deals per se they told
themselves that they did even though
many of them didn't actually have the
economic understanding to really get
what it meant but it's that they saw in
Trump the guy that would prevent people
in Asia or Hispanics from Latin America
from taking their jobs away and thus
questioning or putting in peril their
status Asians and factories weren't
going to be as likely to take jobs if
Donald Trump was the president is it
because of nuance to understand
of how Trump would do trade no but it's
the idea that it would protect their
status in society and when you look at
the results and you pair them up with
Trump policy ideas I guess we'd call
them very generally policy ideas old
they don't all actually translate to
real policy it makes a lot of sense
there's this sort of psychology of
superiority of privilege that exists and
if you see Hispanics or immigrants or
minorities non-christians women if you
see them as achieving not superior but
equal status in society comparatively
you're losing status right and that will
influence you to vote for the candidate
who you at least perceive might help you
maintain that status this relates to
minimum wage phenomenon one of the
income groups when you do surveys of who
supports an increase to the minimum wage
and who is against an increase to the
minimum wage it's not the upper middle
class that overwhelmingly opposes
minimum wage increases it's not the rich
or the ultra rich although some do
oppose it it's not even often the middle
class the people making just more than
minimum wage are one of the groups that
most commonly opposes increases to the
minimum wage because what separates them
from the minimum wage workers not that
much in their mind and it is the exact
same psychological phenomenon that we
see here among a lot of Trump voters and
by the way when you look at history and
you look at when politics has been done
to avoid losing some kind of privileged
status be it a real privilege status or
a perceived privilege status things
often don't go well at all so I think
that in addition to the sort of
coalescing and catalyzing of a lot of
these extremist groups that we've seen
under Donald Trump the idea of people
voting to prevent a loss of what they
see as a privileged status is also a
really concerning thing I also wonder
how this will influence the Bernie would
have won crowd OH the idea behind that
theory was that Bernie was an economic
populist so he wouldn't have lost those
Rust Belt states like he wouldn't have
lost Pennsylvania in Michigan because he
talked about
trade and he talked about NAFTA but
Bernie didn't do that race-baiting stuff
he didn't do that right-wing identity
politics so maybe there's a case to be
made that Trump couldn't be Bernie - I
don't know there is it that these
numbers certainly go more towards that
story than the one that we have heard
which is Bernie definitely would have
won I actually don't know the answer to
that because the entire the entire
general election campaign would have
been very different if Trump was running
against Bernie Sanders so I don't know
how useful it is to really speculate
about Bernie would have won or Bernie
would not have won I know that I would
have voted for Bernie in the general the
same way I voted for him and the in the
primary had he been the candidate I'm
gonna be very interested to see data
from the upcoming midterms outlining
what factors motivate voting one way or
the other because you'll have this
potential you've got the economic
anxiety narrative you've got the fear of
losing privileged status narrative and
then you also have now the sort of
counter Trump move or influence momentum
which has led to a lot of democratic
wins and special elections over the last
year so certainly midterm 2018 data will
be very interesting to look at I have a
story for you today that is both
childish and very disturbing which is
actually a surprisingly common
combination in the current era it's
being reported that the president is
increasingly using his personal mobile
phone to call people without chief of
staff John Kelly knowing about it and
arguably it's also to get around White
House records of the calls that take
place and the sort of immediate obvious
question is who is Trump calling that he
doesn't want John Kelly to know about
and what is it that they're talking
about during these phone calls and we
know because multiple sources inside the
White House have revealed it that when
Trump uses the White House switchboard
system to make calls it generates a log
it generates a list of calls that goes
to the chief of staff formerly it was
Reince Priebus now it's John Kelly
when Trump uses his personal cell phone
it is much more difficult for John gall
Kelly to know what's going on unless
someone tells him hey by the way Trump
called XY or Z and this is very very
telling especially when you consider why
it was that John Kelly was brought in
and
of the changes that happened right after
John Kelly was brought in he came in
replacing Reince Priebus and was sort of
seen as the guy who was gonna get the
riffraff out of the Oval Office
very quickly Sean Spicer left anthony
scaramouche II was out
Steve Bannon was gone and as sources in
the white house say Trump is trying to
get Kelly out of the way as a gatekeeper
by using his mobile phone and to
continue talking to some of these people
there are unrelated reports that say
Corey Lewandowski is in touch directly
with Trump on his mobile phone
Lewandowski was Trump's former very very
wacky campaign manager and John Kelly
specifically tried to put some distance
between Trump and Lewandowski obviously
because Lewandowski is an absolutely
terrible influence on Trump so we have
kind of like a political question the
concern politically is who's Trump
talking to what are they talking about
and how is that influencing Trump's
position on policy the legal question is
about the White House Records and about
security concerns the White House
switchboard system is designed for
sensitive topics to be discussed it's a
secure system it is a tracked system
it's logged and it is private is Trump
talking about classified information on
his personal phone because anyone could
be taking advantage of the security
vulnerabilities on Trump's personal
phone and those conversations would not
be logged and captured just for
government accountability and
transparency they could also be
intercepted by foreign powers or even by
American intelligence and that's sort of
where my curiosity is on this thing
right number one could Trump's personal
phone be bugged by a foreign
intelligence service that's the obvious
question but question number two about
Trump's personal cell phone use is is it
possible that one of our own
intelligence services is surveilling
Donald Trump's phone and this is
potentially a major breach of security
protocol and remember this is the guy
who ran on Hillary can't be trusted
because of her emails and her email
server and documents and humi Abedin
it's all sloppy and let's lock her up
and
usual projection is there anything the
guy accused Hillary or Obama of that
he's not doing himself yeah and as with
all things in the Trump administration
it could be a question too of if this is
incompetence or if it's something
nefarious because maybe he's doing this
deliberately it could be a way to
establish a back-channel with another
entity could be the Russians I don't
know I mean it gets a little bit
conspiratorial but we do yamp at all
going completely full in on completely
unproven conspiracies but who can blame
the guy right because look at what's
been going on for the last 15 months but
no I think that the key question always
applies here which is is Donald Trump
like the incompetent kid hiding from
mommy and using his mobile phone so that
John Kelly doesn't get a printout of who
he talked to or is it actually far more
calculated into various and you never
know what's happened to John Kelly - I
mean the guy is a Marine Corps general
yeah and then he was the director of the
Department of Homeland Security super a
little firm grace now he's just the
caretaker and he might be out soon and
that's actually the next thing that I
want to talk about